hey hello everybody and welcome to my
introductory flipping guide today we are
going to go over what is flipping how
this applies to RuneScape and the ground
exchange and how you can be successful
at it without much experience at all and
yeah let's jump into it so to start off
what is flipping and flipping is
essentially just buying something for a
low price and selling it for a high
price if you imagine a pawn shop or a
auction house or something like that
that's basically what they do so in the
real world people will go out uh they'll
buy stuff for very cheap from people and
they'll go sell it at a high price
usually on a third party Marketplace or
directly back to a manufacturer or
something like that and yeah so it's
pretty much the essentials of what it is
it's very basic but can be very complex
at the same time yes I understand this
uh this diagram doesn't actually make
any sense cuz the the high side should
be lower but um just pretend you are
holding it up over there that's you the
little stick man so how this applies to
RuneScape is RuneScape inherently has
its own Marketplace as part of the game
now how RuneScape used to work was kind
of like the pawn shop or the auction
house you would buy things from people
face to face and you would sell them um
right directly to the person um you can
see the illustration here the guys you'd
have to spam all day saying I'm buying
lobsters I'm buying lobsters then
someone would come along and they buy
your lobsters from you kind of like a
stall um but now RuneScape is more like
eBay or Amazon you have this huge Global
Marketplace that everyone can put their
stuff on and it basically will sell
itself you don't have to sit there all
day and
spamming the same message over and over
and over again so this has a massive
benefit to people who are flipping
mainly in the fact it saves a bunch of
time okay so we are at the Grand
exchange and we will just quickly go
over some of the tools that we have
available and just built right into the
grand exchange uh so start off um if you
right click on the grand exchange clerk
you'll come up with some options
exchange will be your offer slots so for
buying and selling things you'll always
come here um next you'll have the
history uh which will show your last 10
transactions and this will be useful
when you want to check how much money
you've made from your flips or need any
other historical data and lastly here we
have the sets option which isn't used a
lot in flipping but sometimes you might
use it it's for combining and
dismantling sets of armor for the most
part
okay so now we're going to do a test
flip essentially just to show you guys
how to use the gr exchange interface to
buy and sell things so we'll start off
by buying an item we'll do um the nature
Rune uh cuz it's pretty easy to see the
differences so we'll type in nature Rune
we'll find the item right there and
we'll get an interface open so basically
we're looking to find the margin of the
item the margin being the difference
between what someone is selling item for
and what people are buying item for that
difference is where we're going to make
our money from so we're going to start
off by taking an item and we're going to
jack it up quite a bit so we will
instantly buy it off of somebody and
we'll explain exactly how this works in
a second so we'll go ahead U we'll put
it in for 300 um again these triple dots
will actually let you put an exact price
if you want so if you click it you can
type in
275 or you can just Jack It Up by 5%
every time or decrease it if you have to
um but for this case we'll just put in
for 300
[Music]
and hit the confirm button um so you've
noticed it has instantly bought and we
bought it for 257 coins so what has
happened is since we put an offering for
300 coins it has matched us with the
lowest sell price it could so the gr
exchange is really trying to get you the
best deal possible so at the time the
lowest somebody was selling it for that
hadn't already sold uh was
257 so now we'll go ahead and sell the
[Music]
item and for this case we'll just fam
this to bring it down to around 200
coins and the item has instantly sold um
and you notice we sold it for
255 so again on this side of the
spectrum what has happened is it has
matched us with the highest that
somebody has been buying it for and that
hasn't already been boughten from
somebody else so somebody had an
offering for 255 which was the highest
at the time and it completed it for us
so you can see there U the difference
between the two items is two coins and
what that is is the items margin
uh the margin is where we're going to
make all the
money okay so now we're going to do a
couple um example flips for you guys so
we'll just go ahead and start looking
for items basically at first you're just
going to be picking random items you're
not going to really know uh what items
are good but I'd recommend just starting
off with some items that you know are
very common people use a lot so let's
try um H raw Lobster uh so we're going
to go find the item jack up the price
hit confirm uh it'll go through we'll
note down that price so 160 what we're
buying it for and we'll do the same
thing drop it down and we sold it for
155 so that's actually not too bad of a
margin for the item uh so we could go
ahead and do the raw lobsters again you
can hit the history tab uh just to
double check what the margin is so what
we're looking at is 5 GP margin um per
Lobster we buy so we'll go ahead and um
do that so we'll go back to the Grand
exchange we'll go to the Buy offer slot
we'll put in raw lobsters again uh but
this time we're going to set an exact
price of
155 um so now if we buy one and sell it
we'll get 5 GP just like our um little
example guy with vanica um but instead
of doing one we'll do uh we can't afford
oh yeah we'll do 1K lobsters how about
start with 1K lobbies and uh we'll see
how quickly this will buy I don't think
it should take too long uh but yeah
we'll come back once they
bought okay so the lobsters have bought
H that took probably about half an hour
just to he one ing um so yeah now we
will go ahead and claim the the lobsters
so we got 1,000 lobsters
for 155 each and now we will go ahead
and sell them for
160 put them in there for
160 and yeah we will wait for these to
complete and there we go we have
successfully sold all 1,000 lobsters
again really did not take that long so
go ahead and collect it and we'll see
how much money we actually made so we'll
go to the history tab again and um there
is an offer in the way but just ignore
that you can see uh the difference
between the two is 5gp and we got 1,000
so that gave us 5,000 GP profit in total
which is pretty good considering it only
took us about half an hour now if we had
bought um 10,000 other that would have
been
50k so you can see how this could add up
very quickly um if you flip items like
this so go ahead and do one more
example okay so we're going to do one
more example here I think for for the
next one we're going to do the death
Rune just another quick item we can show
so we'll go ahead put in an offer for
the high price we bought at
4248 and we can sell up
4 245 so again has a 3gp margin on it
and these are very quick to buy so we'll
go ahead and do this so death
Rune at
245 and we'll do another
thousand and there we go we have bought
the death runes for 245 so we'll go
ahead and claim them 1,000 and again
we'll be selling them for
248 um so we'll go ahead put them back
in for 248 again using the triple do
button to set an exact price and yeah
these uh bought probably within 5
minutes so hopefully they'll sell within
a few minutes as well okay there we go
we have sold the death runes uh so we'll
go ahead and claim the offer and just
quickly go to our history tab here um so
you see we sold them for a 3gp margin we
got 1,000 death runes giving us 3K so
nothing like amazing but you could see
had it bought 10,000 runes that would
been 30k within 20 minutes really if you
got 100,000 runes over a couple days
that' be 300K so again once you start
having the cash to do so you can buy a,s
tens of thousands even Millions
sometimes of items and then you can make
actually some decent money so now what
items are good to flip and this is
something that cannot really be taught
to you it's kind of something you have
to learn on your own um the reason for
that is because items are always
changing in price things are never going
to be good forever so you can't really
base what items you're going to do off a
list or what off something else somebody
else tells you CU again it's never going
to stay the same that being said here
are a couple categories um that you'll
be able to find some items that will be
good to flip but again just start buying
and selling them you'll find something
good eventually and you'll make yourself
some money and that about wraps it up
guys I hope you enjoyed my beginner
flipping guide uh if you're still
struggling to find items that have good
margins on them you can have a look at
my 0 to 100 Mil uh flipping progress
videos uh which will be on the left
there I go over a bunch of different
items every episode so they're generally
different you can see exactly how well
they do uh also if you feel like you are
at a more Advan flipping level you can
go check out my Advance flipping guide
which will show you some other
techniques on how to find good items um
some external tools I use to calculate
what the best flips are and I go over
some other stuff in that guide as well
again thanks for watching guys and I'll
see you guys later